I'm desperately trying to pass along on
my thoughts to help you to understand
how the world order is changing
um and it's changing in three very
important ways it's changing financially
and economically and important ways that
you can see it's changing because of the
great internal conflict that's happening
and it's also changing because of the
external conflict these three things are
coming together to create a perfect
storm of sorts and I want to help you
understand that by passing it along I'm
doing that in a couple of ways I've
written a book principles for dealing
with the change of world order I have
done a free animated video called The
Changing World Order I'm on these social
posts in the way that we're now
interacting if you take your questions
and you post them in the comments I'm
going to take the best questions and I'm
going to answer them I'll answer them
here and I'm going to answer them across
my social so everyone could benefit so
it's there for you if you want it and if
you don't want it it's okay I'm at a
stage in my life 74 years old and where
I feel compelled to pass that along to
you so it's there for you to take your
leave